GOPAL ASHOK: Hello.
I'm Gopal Ashok, product
manager for Cloud Memorystore.
Cloud Memorystore is Google
Cloud Platform's in-memory data
store service.
The beta release of
Cloud Memorystore
supports Redis,
which, as you know,
is one of the most popular
in-memory data stores
available today.
Getting started with
Cloud Memorystore is easy.
Once you go to the Google
Cloud console, go to the menu.
And if you scroll
down onto Storage,
you will see the
Memorystore option.
If you click on the
Memorystore option,
it'll take you to the
Memorystore landing page.
If you're creating Memorystore
for the first time,
the Google Cloud console
will automatically
enable the API for you.
In this particular case, I
have created a few instances
already.
But let's go in and
create a new instance.
To create a new instance, click
on Create Instance button.
Once you click on
Create Instance button,
it will take you to the
Create Instance page.
The first thing that
you need to provide
is the instance
ID, which uniquely
identifies the instance
that you're provisioning.
Once you have provided
the instance ID,
you can optionally also
provide a display name,
which is a more descriptive
name for the instance.
When you provision a Cloud
Memorystore instance,
we provision Redis version 3.2.
Behind the scenes, we ensure
that all the critical patches
are applied so that you
don't have to worry about
whether there are any
security vulnerabilities
that you need to worry about.
The next thing you need to
choose is the service tier.
Cloud Memorystore provides
due two tiers of service--
basic and standard.
The basic tier provides a
standalone instance of Redis,
and this tier is great
for simple caches.
The standard tier provides
a highly-available Redis
instance.
With a highly-available
Redis instance,
you get both a
master and a replica.
Once you select tier,
select the region.
With Cloud Memorystore, you can
only connect to the instances
within the same region.
So if you choose US
Central 1, applications
within US Central 1 can connect
to that particular instance.
Once you choose a
region, you can either
choose a particular
zone where the master
instance will be deployed,
or you can choose Any.
If you choose Any,
we automatically
pick the zone for the master
and the replica instance.
The next thing
you want to select
is Instance Capacity or the
size of the Redis instance.
Memorystore allows
you to choose anywhere
between 1 and 300 gigabytes.
And depending on the
size, as you can see,
the instance will provide
different network throughput.
For 300 gigabytes, you
can see that you'll
get about 1,500
megabytes per second.
And for 1 gigabyte, you get
about 375 megabytes per second.
Once you've selected the right
size for your application,
the next thing
you need to select
is a network, or the VPC
network where the instance is
going to get deployed.
The VPC network
determines which VMs
can connect to the instance.
Once you've selected
the network,
you can also choose
the eviction policy,
if you choose to change it
from the default. In this case,
I'm going to select allkeys-lru.
And then you go down
and click Create.
Once you click Create, you
can see that the instance
is getting provisioned.
But before I tell you how
to connect to the instance,
I just want to quickly
touch upon how easy it is
to scale a deployed instance.
Now, if you want to change the
size of a deployed instance,
you click on the instance
and click on the Edit button.
Once you go into the Edit
page, all you need to do
is change the size
of the instance.
So if you want to change 1 GB
to 5 GB, just change the size
and click Save, and
we automatically
scale the instance for you.
One thing to note here
is that the basic tier--
when you scale a
basic tier instance,
we fully flush the cache,
and also the application
gets disconnected.
But in standard
tier, the scaling
is mostly an online
operation where
you will lose connectivity
for a brief period,
and there may be a little
bit of data loss because
of unreplicated data.
So as you can see,
it is very easy
to create and scale a Redis
instance using Memorystore.
Now let's take a look at how we
can connect to the Memorystore
instance.
As you can see, when we deploy
the Memorystore instance,
we deploy using a
private IP address.
This is great because your
Redis instance is automatically
protected from the internet,
because it can only be
connected using a private IP.
Cloud Memorystore is also fully
Redis protocol compatible.
So you can run Redis
benchmark against it.
And let's see how it goes.
As you can see, when
you run the benchmark,
you get pretty good throughput
with the Cloud Memorystore
instance that you've deployed.
So the next obvious question is,
how do I monitor the instance?
To monitor the instance, there
are multiple ways to do it.
If you go into the details of
an instance in Cloud Console,
there are a few metrics that
we have published that you can
use to monitor the instance.
But we have more
detail monitoring
available in Stackdriver.
And with the
Stackdriver integration,
a lot more of the metrics
are available through
the Stackdriver dashboard.
As you can see, if you
go into Stackdriver,
you can see all the key
metrics that you need
to monitor a Redis instance.
As you can see, Average Commands
Per Second, the 95th Percentile
Latency, Cache Hit Ratio, et
cetera, are all available.
And these are important
metrics that you
need to determine how your
instance is functioning.
If you want to see the full
list of all the metrics
that are available, just go
to Metrics Explorer, type
in Redis, and you can see
the full list of metrics that
are published in Stackdriver.
So as you can see,
with Cloud Memorystore,
creating, managing, and
monitoring a Redis instance
is actually very easy.
So in short, with
Cloud Memorystore
you don't have to worry
about maintaining your own VM
to manage your Redis instance.
Instead, you can simply
click a few buttons
and then create, manage,
and monitor the instance.
So in summary, let's take a
quick look at the offering.
With Cloud Memorystore,
you have a basic tier
and a standard tier.
And within the tiers, you
also have memory tiers,
which give you different memory
sizes with different network
performance.
As you can see, the
M1 capacity tier
gives you 3 gigabits per
second, while M5 gives you
about 12 gigabits per second.
Also, with respect
to pricing, you
get a wide range
of pricing options
that allows you to choose
the right tier for you.
So as you can see, basic
M1 is less than $0.05
per gigabyte hour, and
the standard instance
are a little bit more.
Basic tier is ideal
if you want to have
a low-cost, simple Redis cache.
[MUSIC PLAYING]